Hey, everybody in the studio, can I have your attention for a second here?
Nick, Nick
Nick, I need your attention.
What?
Uh, we have a drive with errors on the Corridor RAID.
It's showing that the... the drive is at risk.
So if you guys have important files,
Now's the time to go with me into the back room and verify that they are copied over.
We went over this, and when... and when the RAID broke down the first time, I was like, Nico...
We shouldn't do a RAID system again. And he's like,
"Oh, it'll be fine."
and...
(laughs)
Here we are, here we are, less than two years later.
*angry Sam scream*
About to sub the PUBG edit,
but this Origin computer sound driver keeps crashing.
Have you seen the latest edit?
Mm-mm. I'm expecting that Sam's put his own twist on it, and there's probably some good ideas in there...
I'm also expecting it to miss a couple of things I'm trying to do with it. What'll probably be the case is
I'll probably work in the beats that I'm looking for, and keep a lot of the cool like, snappy stuff that Sam's worked in as well.
Some things, especially in action scenes, they don't- they don't register until the piece is completely done.
Because there's visual effects, sound, and music that contribute towards certain things being recognizable beats of the scene.
Interesting ideas in there, umm...
But a lot of the pacing is very different than what I'm looking for. Gonna try to edit it to be what I intended.
When we did Lifeline - well y'know, we got notes from a billion different people, so - you know, all the townspeople are working on it,
they didn't do a bad job or anything like that, but with the Corridor channel right now
I have a little bit of that baggage where when I direct something right now,
I want it to be exactly what I want it to be. Maybe to the detriment of the piece - who knows - and god- *Merlin's pants*
fantastic *subscribe* track record with the videos in the channel this year, so
(laughs)
If you're going to go back on somebody's work, if you're going to...
change it, like I need to... I need to get it really polished
because I can't just show like, a janky rough cut of my idea,
because it's gonna look like garbage up against an actual refined edit -
no matter what kind of edit that is. If I don't get this edit done before Sam gets back from his trip,
it's going to be a lot harder for me to make this edit reflect what I was trying to do
when I was directing the piece, because everybody's going to look at my edit - if it's not finished -
and just think it looks way worse than what Sam's put together.
What's happenin?
Umm...
Server's acting up a little bit, sooo... I came in here to restart it.
I dunno...
-Everything's backed up to a few days ago.
-Yeah, but we've done a lot of stuff since...
Mkay... uhh, Carmichael
We gotta do some biiiig data dumps.
Here's what I'm thinking - and it's kind of risky:
But it'd be the fastest option. I backup our most recent projects onto a third backup.
I also backup a couple of our like our essential operating things - like VFX materials, sound, all that kind of stuff -
then I go to a completely fresh set of drives, wipe 'em, drop the new stuff on there...
But for that one moment when they're wiped, we only have everything in one spot.
I don't like that idea. (laughs)
Relax.
(sighs) Dude...
There's a backup right now, it's fine. The backup RAID backs-up every night - until no one checks it, and there's a power loss,
and then we lose a week of work.
(exasperation intensifies)
Anyway, what I'm tryin to do is summarize the entire Bill of Rights in 30 seconds.
The RAID is down.
And I can't work on the PUBG edit. So I gotta fix the RAID first before I can work on the PUBG edit.
Right now, I need to spend the day working on the frickin RAID, and not on my edits, so...
This whole goal of getting this done is getting pushed back.
When- when does Sam get here?
Uhh... Sam gets back... (sighs)
-Sam!
-Dude, that was the longest drought of my life.
...but it was worth it.
Speaking of drives...
(laughter)
Is there... is there a RAID issue?
Yeah, we're having a... a drive supporting errors on the RAID, so...
Everything's all backed up onto the backup RAID at this point
Umm...
With me about to do a triplicate backup before jumping into fixing the main RAID.
Cool.
-Oh, yeah, this is perfect timing.
-Hey, Spencer.
Do you like to drive?
-Yes?
-I don't what's...
-Great.
Carmichael's just like, he loves puns, because he's talking about disk drives now, because we have a bad one in the Corridor RAID! Woo!
What!?
(laughter)
And they were playing choppy... Everything else is generally copying over pretty quick...
-Uhh, there's one file in particular that's not reading, umm...
-That's a good program.
-What's that?
-It's good plugin.
Particular?
-Ugh, god- *truck*
-Deep learning.
There's a- there's a Western Digital program you can get that we'll do a smart test, so just...
I would love to get back on here and edit though, which I'll do after lunch, so...
I sat down, and basically, what a couple of things I really liked:
that opening shot with the force field,
that umm right at the top? Like, that's great. And then Carmichael had a suggestion,
which is to make that shot either the POV of the C-130,
or have the C-130 enter the shot.
Oh, and I went back and I wanted to just try editing what I had directed for...
You'll notice there's a lot of stuff not used/cut with the guy, the the the the Anonymous squad.
A lot of time on set was spent filming these close-up shots.
Yeah, and these guys - they literally have numbers next to their names in the script - they could not be any more meaningless.
You know, Enemy #1, Enemy #2 - it's like, I would just say like, my main critique of the... the process
from filming it, to editing it, to like, what will end up being the final product though,
I think bringing a little more clear direction into how you shoot this opening scene -
not the run- no, the running was like five shots, but then there's you see
there's this block of like, seventeen clips,
of these just guys walking around talking, and we're gonna spend no time with these characters in the final piece.
So it's like...
Taking some of that forethought and bringing it to on set there to just, kind of make things a little more...
Spend less time shooting it, knowing you're not gonna need a lot of footage, focus on...
Maybe the fight sequence, or so - you know that kind of thing.
-Yeah.
-So that's- that's my big critique that I just need to get out of the way because...
-No, that's- that's good. It actually...
Carmichael had a good suggestion for in Scene 2
which is: up to that point, up to the scene where they stop and they're walking in the trees?
Everything's very handheld, and we're- we're with them, we're in the action, and then we got a couple of those dolly shots...
And so if you actually commit to no handheld stuff,
like, so, it's like you're in the action, in the action, running, jumping, shooting, then he hides, and boom- dolly shots.
And you stay in the dolly shots
-until *spoilers for their PUBG movie*
-Oh.
So it's like, you're like, you're with him, you're with him, you're like out watching as the third part- party viewer,
like, you know, getting cinematic, and then boom: back into it.
And that's actually... there's a really nice cinematography change.
There's an- there's actual bots on YouTube that scan content,
that scan the image of the thumbnail, scan tags...
But one of the things that some of the bots look for are inappropriate languages with a-
and they have a list of words and what they- those words would sound like, so...
The safest way to do it is try to incorporate bleeping out words.
What if we didn't use normal bleeps, and like, we actually just recorded...
Dude, that- when Sam like, Sam will just like, do this really funny scream... (laughs)
I can't even explain it. It's like...
(suppressed scream)
Basically it... So like, I think, let's go record some Sam.
What are you doing?
So... so we want to start bleeping out swear words.
-On the channel, and...
-But we don't want to use bleeps...
Yeah, that's super boring. So could we get some of your- your famous screams?
-Screams? I thought we were gonna just...
-Sam
Let me see you when you're really angry.
I thought we- I thought we were just gonna do like bleeping it with like, 'tarnation.'
Have you guys ever seen Sam, when he's angry? He's really scary.
-No, I'm not screamin, I'm not- don't...
-(laughter)
-Just give us one to use, man.
-Just one, man.
Dude, I found a list: "101 Great Swear/Cuss Word Alternatives."
-(laughs)
-What are they?
-For kids.
...'Merlin's pants.'
'Ceaser's ghosts.'
'Fiddlesticks' - love that one. 'Snicker doodles.'
Wow, these are like, this the worst.
That... I just sent you on Slack the Advertiser's Guideline or Advertiser-Friendly Guideline...
Words and how words sound are being searched through YouTube videos via bots,
to be de-monetized.
*shuzzbutt*
(laughter)
Dude...
That sucks.
Dude, Sam, does that make you angry?
Yeah, it does. It's makin me sooo angy.
(shudders)
-Oh no...
(rage intensifies)
-There's one comin!
(angry Sam noises)
(suppressed Sam scream)
(laughter)
(more laughter)
Oh my god, that was *fiddlesticks* amazing.
(even more laughter)
Give me- give me a variety of the word 'subscribe.'
Subscribe. Subscribe! SUBSCRIBE!
Sub-ub-ubscribe.
Look up some Welsh swear words and then try to pronounce them.
(incoherent Welsh swearing)
"Farting like a sheepdog on a short chain." That's what I just said.
Real quick, just say sentence with a bunch of swear words in it. Go.
You'll- it'll never go on the internet.
Nah.
Here, you do it, Jake.
Mother-*Sam scream*
-Perfect.
-Nice, n-now say a sentence that incorporates swear words, but there are some words in between that aren't swear words, like... MadLibs.
Do it real angry.
Have you ever seen those mother-*subscribe* who will always suck *dillweed*
I'm gonna kill those shi-*Merlin's pants*
-Great test.
-Wow.
That can- that can never go on the internet, ever.
That's horrible!
-Hey, what's up?
-Which LUTs are the best LUTs to go buy?
-The best LUTs to go buy?
Previously it was IWLTBAP.
Right now?
-It's our LUT pack.
-What? We have a LUT pack?
-Yeah, that's right actually guys
I have been hard at work for the past week here, taking some of our best looking videos and making
look-up tables for them - basically look presets. They are literally taking the color grades that I have made for our videos
and I'm giving them to you guys. Well, for a price, because I put a lot of work into them, trying to make sure they even work across
a whole bunch of different types of footage, and making sure I give out LOG versions, Rec.709 versions... Anyways, in other words
we are selling some of our looks from our videos - our color grades - and if you guys would like to check them out,
head on over to creatorpresets.com
That is where they are on sale, along with a whole bunch of other look-up tables and presets
and I think lightroom presets as well for photography. Sawyer Hartman, a friend of ours, is putting it together.
He wanted to basically create a way that different
YouTubers and photographers and instagramers could all get together and share some of the tools of what they do.
Out with people like you.
Anime Fidget Spinner, Nerf Team Fortress - with like the punchy kind of oranges and reds that really bring out the Nerf guns - to color grades from
The Division, which give us like a really gritty, cinematic look.
A really hipster film grade from the Master Chief Doesn't Want to Die video.
I have Jason Bourne Teaches Thanksgiving - everybody does the Hollywood blue and teal these days,
but this one takes a step in the yellow and green direction.
We have Nerf John Wick, my second favorite one in the bunch which is
The Poacher color grade, and they spent a long time on that back in the day putting it together.
That one really makes any forest scene just come to life really well.
We have my favorite one: the Assassin's Creed 3 summer-to-fall look.
-Wow.
-So this is what it's like summertime, so it's like...
So, summertime... fall.
And, you can use this in any program that supports look-up tables, heck, even like put it into your monitor for your camera -
if it supports that - so you can actually see your footage through a lookup table,
which is pretty cool. And technically you're gonna get 18, because you're getting a LOG version and a Rec.709 version of each one.
Don't forget to subscribe!